Hello, I'm Linda you and you kind of missed that author of the great economists.
Welcome to this special video episode of the intelligence squared podcast.
A reminder that you can sign up for regular updates about podcasts and other
events@intelligencesquared.com.
I'm here with Mark [inaudible] professor of international economics at Brown
university and Eric Lonergan, a London-based macro hedge fund manager.
Their new book is angry Nomics,
and I'm delighted to explore the stimulate you book with them in this
podcast. So I'm just going to kick off and start. I'm going to ask each of you,
why did you write the book and see if your answers match up Mark
first.
We wrote the book because Eric and I used to hang out at a finance conferences.
The reason I was hanging out the finance for instance was because I was writing
like prior book on austerity and I wanted to meet bond market
vigilantes.
Eric is the least likely vigilante I've ever met and we hit it off and we
decided it would be fun at some point to write a book,
but we could never find the time.
And then we came up with an elegant technological solution, Eric, over to you.
Yeah, definitely. I mean, I think there's no doubt our sort of friendship,
um, was a big part, no two ways about it.
And it's a very interesting exercise in collaboration.
I find working with Mark because I think, and this will,
hopefully this will come through and it comes through in the book.
We all very different in many ways. Um,
not just because he supports football teams that aren't going anywhere. Um,
I I'm kidding, but, uh, yeah, w we're very different,
but we work really well together, you know,
and one thing that's great about Mark as a collaborator is there's,
there's very little ego, so we've, I think we've got a nice mix. I mean,
you'll notice Linda when you're trying to collaborate with people,
it's really hard.
If people are very precious about what they say or possess and we just really
hit it off. Well, I think that's the sort of, you know,
the personal case for it. The idea,
I think we just really felt that, that we,
we had an insight into what was happening in the world.
That was one key thing from a kind of political economy perspective,
even though our starting points in some respects are different.
And then the crux was, was a discovery that anger,
this very strange emotion that everybody is familiar with,
but nobody really understands, um,
is the arc that brings it all together. Um,
I think that was really the Genesis of this book,
friendship and anger.
But you're missing one point.
It also makes things theory because we recorded the book.
The reason it's dialogues is because we actually sat down and did it with a
couple of iPhones. So that's why it has that unusual structure.
And then what was fascinating is we took it out of the dialogue and couldn't
enter text.
And when we read at market value and read exactly like all these other books
were pointy-headed geeky,
50 year old Rex white men tell the world what's wrong with us.
We thought this is awful. This is the right tablet.
So we put it back into dialogue and suddenly it was much better.
So from that point on, we knew what we had and it was a dialogue.
You just answered. My second question, which is, it's a really unusual format.
It's a series of dialogues and between the two of you,
which I think really brings the issues to life.
So I'm just going to delve now into the issue. So you define and green omics,
um, as any kind of,
of heightened uncertainty and anger were faith in the workings of markets and
politicians has been undermined you both set out to explain and
propose what to do about it. So just tell us a bit more about the premise.
I'll start with you, Eric.
I think that's important to understanding the thesis and then Mark can sort of
pick this up is, is the, the concept of anger itself. So,
so one of the things that's intriguing about anger is it's so
prevalent, you know, eat children, know what anger is.
Every human being has experienced or felt anger at some point in time.
And yet we're very inarticulate when it comes to, I guess. So if I said to you,
what are the different types of anger? What function does anger serve?
Why do we get angry? Is there good anger? Is there bad?
Anger is private anger, the same as public anger.
We don't have a given vocabulary for making sense of this.
It's just sort of assumed that we understand it. Um,
and so the first part of the thesis was to try and make sense of anger, right?
And, and we did a load of reading and anger is covered in so many disciplines.
There's neuroscience, there's moral philosophy, the social psychology,
the psychology, the self-help books, all covering anger,
but nowhere really did we find a satisfactory typology or synthesis
out. We kind of through a very, through an interesting process,
we came up with this type apology, which is there, it's almost like there's, Oh,
there's an angelic and a devilish form of anger, right? And,
and the first kind of binary form is this between public and private.
So what's really interesting is when you see private public expressions of
anger, like extinction rebellion, protestors,
or re the righteous anger of, of black lives matter, um,
it's, it's actually argued, justify, um,
there's almost pride in the anger because it's righteous anger.
Let's put it like that in the private sphere.
It's typically associated with shame, right?
If you had a colleague who was suddenly getting angry,
you'd take them to one side and say, is everything okay at home?
It tells us about an internal stress or anxiety. So again,
you have this sort of duality where they seem like opposites,
and then the second component.
So you have private and public have very different,
but then the two faces of public anger, right? We have this,
this moral we've described.
But also, and this is the football reference. We've we came upon this,
this idea of the angry fam,
which anybody who's gone to a sort of big sporting event will identify with.
And they're a very curious phenomenon and why do they exist?
And we sort of identified this as, as they become identity regulators.
Um, so this is the type apology that kind of is a starting point for,
for setting us up to understand angry Nomics.
Mark, did you want to say something about, well,
you will come to your proposals for the way forward,
but is there anything about the premise you want to tease out at this point?
I'll just add a little bit on of gloss on what Eric said in terms of the two
content guys. So let's take Trump's in his, the mind's all was in the news,
right?
So what did Trump do to surprise so many people in 2016,
he listened to what many people consider was what
was, um, just knowledge. There was no signal.
And what he had was exactly that model overage,
that Midwestern distress,
the 20 years of the industrialization, the neglect,
the abomination effect in cities, that means all the, it was,
they are supply chains and the popped in the communities, and that was there,
but the Democrats were not able to receive the signal.
They just were completely deaf towards it.
And Trump intuitively knew that it was there.
So he went down and he did the most important thing you can do when there are
claims of model outreach, which is, he gave recognition.
He recognized that he said, I am your voice. I hear you.
Then he effortlessly pivots travels down to Arizona or East Texas,
and started going on about Mexicans being rapists. So what is he doing there?
He's using the other side of this, which is a non-regular,
which is using that type of outreach to weaponize it and to what we call
the energy of tribes.
And that's basically what politicians do with that type of anger.
You can push it in a direction where there's information from the model
outreach, which is legitimate and needs to be listened to,
or you can weaponize it by identifying another and creating your own
tribe in that sense. And you can jump very quickly from football finds,
policing their own to essentially the Trump call,
if you're not a lot of form of right wing populism.
Mm Hmm.
And I want to talk about the quote that you start the book with. Um,
you quote, Winston Churchill, quote,
a man is about as big as the things that make him angry.
Why did you choose that to open the book? Um,
Eric sure.
Well, it's a very astute observation, um, as a quote,
because the, we kind of,
if you take this idea of public anger, having these two faces,
um, and indeed private anger, what makes you angry? Uh,
tell us something about your character, right. Um, and,
and so this whole point of the, the functioning as human beings.
That anger serves anger serves multiple functions.
And one of the important functions is this whole point about recognition of an
injustice.
And this dates all the way back to Aristotle the Greek Greek philosophers
thought anger was an appropriate emotion because it identified an
ethical wrongdoing.
And what I find so interesting about this and why it's such a perceptive concept
is there's a great YouTube video at the moment with Cornell West, um,
who I think, I think he's at Princeton now anyway, but sort of,
who's been a long time intellectual advocate of the civil rights movement.
And he, he actually says he's being interviewed on CNN and he pretty much says,
what would it say about our society if people weren't protesting.
Right. And that's exactly that, that, that Greek idea,
which is you're supposed to get our anger angry.
So in the ways that Churchill said it,
ironically in this context that it should be a Churchill quote, um,
it's appropriate that people are affronted, uh,
by these acts of injustice and violence. Um,
but having said that in the sense that it's the measure of your character, the,
the, the anger of tribes, and this is really, really important. I mean, again,
if you read some of the social psychology literature on the history of this,
you know, sporting events in the ancient times, and,
and in recent events as well, can turn very quickly to violence,
brutal violence. And that is indicative. We have to be really,
really careful about this tribal rage. You know, it is,
it is an age old evolved instinct,
which is a precursor to violence. And that's why the bit that we are very,
very concerned about is how politicians are exploiting this to
motivate what are minorities,
but a minority identity regulators in order to tactically win elections.
And that's a very important strain and dimension to what we're,
we're trying to analyze and understand.
Hmm. So Mike, is that why you chose the quote?
And it shows the quote.
I saw the quote when he put it up and I thought that works. Let's go.
I can already tell why you QR success. So coauthors, okay. Let me move into,
um, some of the analysis of the, um,
the anger that you are very well articulate in the book.
Let me just ask you what makes this anger that you described different. Now,
you say there has been long discontent with politicians.
It reminds me of a joke. How do you know a politician is lying?
His lips are moving.
So what causes angry male mix to recur from time to time and why
now, Mark?
So the middle of the book is basically structured as macro angry autonomics and
micro genomics. And there's lots of people,
the sort of the causal story in the book, if you want to use that language. Um,
basically what we see is there's been a kind of train wreck,
which has been suppressed. All right.
And let me briefly explain what I mean by that. We use this analogy as you know,
in the book of capitalism, as hardware and software, just like a computer.
And over time,
basically incompatibilities build up between the economic ideas and rules
governing the system and the name of the system itself.
And it crushes and periodically we've seen that.
So the very first big crash was the end of the gold standard for the great
depression.
Then there was the crash of the seven days of the crisis of inflation and
profitability. And both of those times there were systematic reset.
So if we think about all of the activity done by humans and the thought is it
was everything from the new deal in Swedish, social democracy,
the German fascism, huge attempts to institutionally re-engineer the economist.
When you get to the seven is it's less romantic, but it's just this fundamental,
it's the whole tunnel towards the market, privatized integrate liberalized,
globalize, the whole thing, and write a whole new software code.
The big hardware,
most of the generation of the seventies and eighties was of course,
independent central box and not becomes crucial because the bug in the software
for the 1980s is inequality, which is largely filled in by credit.
We have an enormous credit crunch in 2008. That should have been like the 1970s,
or should it be been a fundamental hardware and software reset,
but there wasn't the central banks just poured liquidity into the service,
then brought it back to life. Well, when you do that,
particularly with started this based upon boosting asset values and an already
highly unequal skewed society of asset holders,
then there are tons of the asset holders increases and everyone else gets
increasingly squeezed.
Then you bought them with a couple of years of austerity and variable growth
building on top of wage stagnation,
which has been going on in some cases for a generation.
And you finally get to a cracking point.
You get to a point where the volatility constraint of just adding more credit to
the system begins to crack.
And this is why we describe populous in a sense is called writer's albeit quote
on quote, quote writers,
because they are trying to write a new UI for the system.
They realize the system is broken,
but they're unable to articulate a coherent if you will,
software pockets to fix it.
So that's basically why now it's a series of outer as buffer outliers that have
been building up over time. There was a crash, there was a bot fix,
and now that bad fix is coming apart.
And Eric, I'm gonna ask you, um,
the you've already done this already in terms of differentiation
differentiating, um, some of the different types of anger. Um,
can you just say that more about tribalism?
So in the book you described tribalism as the reason why football fans will
travel and watch their team play regardless of the weather. Um, you,
then you also see the nationalism is the modern national form of
political tribalism,
what causes tribal identity, um,
which can become quite an angry Nomics.
I mean, this is, it's really fascinating, Linda. I mean, if you.
Look at the literature in social psychology,
there was research that's been done.
That's very well established now in the 1960s, which was effectively the,
the,
the minimum groups paradigm and which was looking at this whole issue about
what caused tribal identities and what forms, what,
what triggers could cause human beings to form groups.
And it is frightening our propensity to break into groups
and that we will make groups based on utterly trivial distinctions,
um, and our sense of group identity and our behavior as a group,
even based on really spurious premises. Okay. So for example, they took,
um, classrooms of children and divided them into which one preferred the
two abstract expression is play and Kandinsky, you know,
which are two too abstract expressionists, Russian artists.
And you separate in a room full of children based on which their preferences.
Um, and,
and you would literally get both group identity and potentially even wrongdoing
towards the other group.
And these studies have been reinforced now where they've even done it with
neuroscience where, um, they've done experiments,
which based on, they will just say you are part of group a,
you are parts of group B where it has no character juristics,
but your sense of allegiance affects you. And it affects our decision-making.
I mean, it, it, it is, it is a very,
very interesting let's put it like that.
Now it's clearly functional because groups are,
are more successful than individuals ultimately. Um,
but it has very dangerous dimensions to it quite clearly as well.
So our propensity, our willingness to create the other as it were, uh,
appears to be very, very deeply hardwired.
And the innovation I think in,
in our book is to identify the role that anger pays in this, because that, to,
to my knowledge in the literature, we don't find identification of this.
So people are aware in the literature angle that angry fat that fans get angry,
but they haven't made this link that says,
actually it appears to be the case that most of us don't wander around
obsessing about our national identity all the time. But you can,
you can switch on this little minority of, of,
of individuals who can kind of trigger a very strong sense.
And once it's brought to our attention,
it's like everybody turns a certain color or shade. Um,
and as, so this propensity is a hard wire. It's a very,
very powerful propensity.
Yeah. I just thought to that two things,
one of them is a great example that not seeing to lab [inaudible],
which is why is all orange juice in the U S culture?
And this is basically the point about the intense preferences of minorities.
You could go to the pro, you could go and make another plant, just do kosher,
but that would be prohibitively expensive, given the numbers.
So you might as well just make like all kosher, right? So in a sense,
my knowledge intense minority preferences tend to win out.
So that's built into it too, but the other side of it,
and this is what I want to talk about. The micro decided this micro economics,
we basically talk about humans dealing with uncertainty. Now, you know,
as economists, we'd all taught to think that Rusk is uncertainty singularly,
not, and by uncertainty,
we mean that basically the state of the probability distribution is no guidance.
So you can have plans. You can think, you know, we can do it.
It's about like Basta investing in an accounting degree,
and then waking up in the world of turbo tax, right? Suddenly you're redundant.
And what the case we make in the book is the combination of aging societies on
more and more advanced technologies, digital technologies, platforming,
et cetera, has made people more uncertain about the future.
And in a fundamental sense, they feel that they cannot control their lives.
So if you are in these very real economic stresses generated by macro crashes,
and then you add these micro stresses to this,
then put in what addicts been talking about.
That's that whole nexus that generates an angry response.
That's how that comes about.
And basically we find ourselves defaulting into tribalism or Klein or
whatever electric, if you want to use for it,
because that gives us the sense of stability that the world denies us,
we'll live in a world. We can increasingly not control,
but we have this illusion that we can control through these not attempts that we
construct about Trump or, or, or, you know, I'm a Bernie I,
or I am a fortune conspiracy theorist or whatever, an anti-vaxxer,
whatever floats your boat,
but we're kind of subjectively trying to create through these groups.
Do these value in tanks groups are very much based upon everybody else being
wrong, a sense of control in our own lives.
Yeah. Yeah. In terms of your micro stressors, that really, I think helps, um,
just kind of fill out, um, how that feeds into, um, the macro picture,
especially around private anger. Now you differentiate, um,
tribalism from legitimate anger. Uh,
you define that as moral outrage. So in that chapter,
you two discuss referendums as a chance for the Electra to show their anger and
vote against those in charge.
So why do we also see more moral anger now? Um,
by the way, I love that to coding and crushing explanation, which,
which I'm sure you just about to mention just now.
Not only that we have, we're going to release a cartoon that explains it.
So you can, I'll send that to you and pass that around. That's in crashes,
I guess it's our claim would not really be that it's not like we're measuring
the frequency and quantity of,
of moral outrage and trying to say there's more now than there has been
historically I don't, we wouldn't be really making that claim.
What we're intrigued rather is,
is trying to understand the form of moral outrage that we're observing
currently. Um, because as, as Mark describes.
This kind of history of forms of capitalism,
and we should get them to talk through it where you you've kind of had three
types of capitalism, and whenever we've had these crashes in the economy,
we've had manifestations of moral outrage. Um, but, but if you think about it,
it becomes, you know,
in many ways it's really clear to us what's happening in the current
environment. And I think this is the kind of optimistic element of the book.
So one really important theme that we have is part of the
reason that we're seeing tribalism exploited by the political elite elites is
that we lack motivating ethical ideology. So,
so we lack, uh, political ideologies that people can be motivated by,
by which they think are going to positively change their societies.
And, and th the moral questions that we're all concerned about are about the
sustainability of the planet.
Uh.
Out the scale of inequality. I think, whatever your perspective
have you sit on a political [inaudible] as well,
concentrated in the hands of the population is clearly not very functional.
So we have, we have moral outrage over the climate.
We have moral outrage over inequality,
and I think the other very important factor,
which is pertinent to current economic environment is recessions.
So what we're really trying to say is we need real solutions to the
problem of recession, global sustainability, um,
and these, and these really need to be addressed.
And that's the source of moral outrage that we're currently experiencing.
Mark. Before I start to ask you, why don't you give sort of, um,
uh, the kind of, uh, overview as it were, um,
about how you want to kind of tie this together with these big picture items
before we move to your proposals for how to change.
I mean,
essentially we have three versions of carbon Elysium kind of gold standard
capitalism based upon openness.
And then we had a much more restricted national form of capitalism where people
made cars and their kids, and at least swap them.
And then that created an inflationary crisis. I think I'd rather go back.
If I may though, to what Alec was just talking about, about, you know,
legitimate, I'm going to let's put something very concrete and recent and give,
so we can solidify in people's minds, right?
Let's think about what's happened in the COVID crisis.
So under the COVID crisis, basically the world central bank,
which is the fed for better or worse has come out and said,
don't worry if you're an asset holder, we've got your back, right?
If you a company and you spent billions, literally billions by button on shares,
and you have no cash, we've got your back, you've got ETFs,
we'll buy them, but at least we'll make a commitment to,
we will cut every falling knife because you're our constituents,
your normal worker screw year, you might get a check every three months.
So what's behind the model.
Outrage is the cemetery of the perk there's been put upon people,
and this is increasing through time.
So just as prices are getting by to be time and more expensive,
every time there's more and more re-insurance for those that can best weather
the crisis. Whereas those who actually are the least protected,
think 18 million Americans who are hourly workers with no
statutory sick pay, valuable or rights art,
well hire and fire possession mainly concentrated in high touch,
low productivity, low skill, low paid jobs. That's,
who's really paying the brunt of this.
So when they watch Boeing get 50 billion like this,
when they watch banks have taken bets on mortgages, get billed out like this,
when they're constantly told there's no money to relieve student loans or for
raising minimum wages and the fed can magic trillions and an afternoon,
why would you not be modeling outraged by that?
Hmm. Hmm. Yeah. Um,
and that's a good point for us to think about what do we do about it because you
do spend, um, the last part of your book with some really interesting, uh,
propose though. So, um, on the proposals to make us less angry,
let's go through some of them. We won't get through all of them. Um,
but I'm intrigued by this national wealth fund,
which provides assets to those who, um, who have none. Um,
Eric, do you want to, uh, talk us through that? So what, so.
I have identified these three legitimate areas of concern,
which are relevant to all of us in our societies
and where there is a very, very strong cross-party consensus,
which is we have to do something about the sustainability of our planet.
We have to tackle wealth inequality, and we have to try and bring recessions,
keep recessions as, as short, um,
as possible causing as least damage as possible. So inequality,
there is a very, very strong consensus,
but there is no real consensus about what to do about it, right?
And one of the kind of benchmarks we gave ourselves is we said, right,
we need real policies that can tackle these problems quickly,
that will be effective. Um, and that are simple to explain, right?
Um,
now the idea of a national and we want to national wealth fund significantly to
try and tackle wealth inequality. And the challenge there is,
there is a very simple one, which is to say,
how can we give ownership of assets to the
large majority of our population were very insignificant levels of asset
ownership because in an increasingly uncertain world,
asset ownership helps you in terms of the quality of your life.
And so one of the interesting things,
and we have to get into a bit of economics here,
but one of the most defining of our current.
Economy, and you will as an economist,
but we'll be aware well aware of this lender is how low the real cost of capital
is to the State right now. What does that mean?
It means that the British government today, for example,
can borrow for 30 years at negative real interest rates.
That means the private sector is paying the government to borrow right now,
all of us economists are pulling out our hair because we're tearing our hair
out, going, why on earth? Aren't we doing lots of investment spending,
because all you need to do is generate a positive return on your investment.
And that actually strengthens the state balance sheet, right?
So there's no issue about the net assets of the state go up.
If you borrow negative real, and you invest the positive way, right?
That's just finance. That's just arithmetic. It's the law of arithmetic.
You can't disagree with. So what Mark and I are saying is, well,
if the Norwegian sovereign wealth fund can generate a 6% return, uh,
over 20 years or Harvard's endowment can, or the welcome trust in the UK,
we have all of these charities, independent organizations,
sovereign wealth funds. Why can the British government, the Irish government,
the German government, the American government,
why can't we all do this as a state? You know,
and the answer is we could easily do it.
We could issue 15% of GDP tomorrow in the bond market,
we could buy a diversified, diversified basket of global assets.
And then by virtue of the arithmetic over 15 or 20 years,
you can repay the debt and you've got the assets and we could,
we could distribute within within 18 months,
we could distribute 15% of GDP to people in the economy who have no assets
currently.
And then they would be able to participate in share in the creation of national
wealth. The idea really is that simple. And it's very difficult,
actually. I don't think we've heard a compelling counter argument.
Hm Hm. Mm. And I think one, uh,
maybe Michael,
pick this out and maybe you could pick that up the line with your second
proposal, which is to revise the fiscal rules to financing like the green,
new deal. One objection. People always have is you're adding to the debt,
um, for both of those things. So Mark, I'll just let you handle that.
Sure. I mean, you don't have to go full modern monetary theory,
but they do make a very bad again, test and in simple point about this,
and then I I'll give you an example of this. I,
I occasionally talked to the U S Navy. I can't tell you why it stops.
I occasionally talk to you as Navy and I have a room full of officers.
And I said to them who fixed the national debt? And I said,
if you could, at the stroke of a pen console, the national debt tomato,
would you do it? And everyone said, yes, is that congratulations, gentlemen,
you've just destroyed. America's national savings.
It's the other side of the balance sheet.
We only have a focus on one side of the balance sheet.
If you're in a negative real environment,
you're able to generate savings assets. That should be a good thing.
And a world of uncertainty, no one.
Ever forces anyone to buy bonds.
The auctions never fail. And yet,
somehow this is the terrible burden that we're giving interest, bearing assets,
the people and the negative real and bottom.
So I just think that that's nonsense to stuff, right.
Let me say a little bit more though, and see if this is useful.
I started to think about the backend of the book, not as policies,
cause I hate that word because it's too technocratic and it doesn't sound to a
politics. It's not under the old view. We're not saying mine,
antibiotic agent follow out. I can Mark. At least not yet. Um,
I think of these things I was following at show, and here's what I mean by this.
If you have a group of people in a room, how you arrange the furniture,
but arguably determine what type of evening they're going to have.
So if I think of what we're arguing for, independent fiscal councils,
the technical very techie stuff,
like negative rates and the fuel rates that I can talk about.
But this is simple to understand stuff like a data dividend that forms the basis
of a kind of quasi UBI. If we do this as well,
fund and margin will happens if you just have that in the economy, right?
Basically every election then changes its dynamics in terms of,
we now have new bits of furniture there, which shape our politics.
And that's what I think is actually really important,
but it's proposal beyond what they do.
The hopefully are able to be supported by both the left thumb,
the right and the by others, and will be seen as assets for society as a whole.
And if you do that,
you change the furniture in the room and you change the type of party you can
have. And I think that that's really important.
Mm. Yeah. It's just a great way of sort of capturing, um,
so much of what you mean, uh, furniture, coding, computers,
crashing cell phones.
[Inaudible] this is true.
My wife often says that I really shouldn't have been in academic.
I should have been an advertising copywriter. Got it. So maybe she's right.
Your wife of course is always right. Yeah.
Yes, of course. Once she gets [inaudible].
Excellent. Um, we, um,
we wanted to have to go through all the proposals,
but I just want to pick out a few that I thought, um,
just to spend a few moments on, um, towards the end of our discussion.
So Mark mentioned there, the data dividend. Um, alright.
What is the daily Ted dividend? Um.
Well the data dividend here is, I mean, again,
so a common theme amongst all of the policies really is to try and
either broaden distribution or access to income and cash flows in
different situations for households and also to try and change due to broaden
the distribution of, of, of wealth to give people more protection. Um,
and the data dividend is a really simple idea, which is we have the,
these huge technology companies who are making incredibly profitable.
They have monopolistic characteristics. Um,
they're not simple monopolies in the old sense because a lot of what they
provide.
Is free, but they certainly have monopolistic characteristics.
The interesting thing is that almost their acid base,
what gives them this value is in fact ours, which is it's our data.
And all we're really suggesting is, um,
why don't we enforce some of our property rights over that data and we could
effectively auction our data. So if we recognize that as a community,
we have a huge amount of valuable data.
And so we're going to auction it in the same way that we auction spectrum to
mobile telephony companies. Um, and as a consequence of that,
that then gives us an asset that we can distribute.
And this is a way of trying to, you know,
we've thought an awful lot about these ideas of universal basic income.
And we've thought that this is a way which a lot of this is about framing and
economic policy and the criticism of universal basic income is it's kind of
something for nothing. Well, this is a
which people are resistant to something that you own and just getting paid for
it, um, which lands very differently in terms of how people perceive it.
I would just add onto that again,
let's bring it into the current moment because I think this proposal is suddenly
become more relevant. Um, obviously you both know, um,
there's an effort to try and get a global minimum corporate tax and also to
basically move on from base erosion to basically taxing sales,
rather than declared profits to have all the double Irish and all this nonsense
and the Americans last week pulled the plugs on it and they pulled the plug on
it because guess what? It's their tech company.
So there's basically said to them, you don't get to talk so tech,
but you get to use Octa. So if you try and talk,
saw tech companies will put tarps on you. This is where we are. All right.
So that's a tough one, but how about the following?
Then we refuse to give you the data, right?
You basically know we'll talk to you another way.
If you want pay a tax for what you provide as a service,
then we will not allow you input data for your profit and you need
to buy it from us. So you can get the team. The effect is that always see detox,
but do it in such a way that you're actually benefiting your citizens at the
same time, rather than just raising a bundle of revenue.
And Eric, you've got a number of other fascinating proposals in there, um,
that, um, Mark has already touched upon. Um,
I'm actually just going to give you free reign.
Is there another one that you want to highlight?
Can I, can I go with this one that I really care about a lot? Well,
which is related to a green new deal, you know,
and this is where I really really think, uh, you know, we,
we all have a moral obligation to do something about this, right? Um,
so because I actually think that the whole challenge of sustainability
is solves our economic problem. It's been presented the other way around, right?
People go, Oh my God, we've got this huge challenge of climate change.
What are we going to do? It's going to require huge sacrifices.
I viewed completely the other way round,
which is thank God we have this great to do loads and loads of
investments spending because I actually,
our economic system is crying out for investment spending. You know, what,
what now? What do I mean by that? Well, I mean,
it goes back to this point about where interest rates are.
We seem to be concerned by the fact that central banks have zero interest rates,
and we show how to do this in the book. But if you use Juul interest rates,
which the European central bank has started to do,
which is if you leave the interest rate on deposits on chain for you to even
raise it, and you cut the rate of interest on lending and targeted lending,
this is rocket fuel. But the key point is nobody is onto this.
And nobody is saying, how do we target this, these loans? Now, if you said,
I'm going to give the private sector 15 year loans at
minus 2% to finance green energy investment,
you will make our economy sustainable within 15 years. I mean, that is just,
that is as close a thing in economics to a certainty and we can do it
if he likes to deal with interest rates. There you go.
I got that sense, Mark. I'm going to give you the same, open-ended um,
kind of final question before I sort of wrap up, um, which is.
What do you want us to take away.
Um, to become less angry about the world.
I want to go back to the formal, external knowledge.
As soon as that seem to work with everyone, you know, we need,
we need to change.
The farmer turned around and we need to change not just the outcomes out our
economy,
but the things that actually generate economic plans and what we are
proposing, basically taking the tech giants on the,
by basically claiming property in the first place on data.
And at the same time, as you use the volatility in markets to issue debt,
to buy off equities, to build a wealth fund, I think that parties that do this,
particularly we can get across part of your agreement on this.
We will change the way that the economy operates,
not just in terms of the outcomes of producers,
but it will create something that's more transparent.
It's fair that people feel that they have a stake in,
and that they don't volume to go back to the whole thing of honor.
So much of honor is about recognition.
And basically if you're recognized as a citizen,
who's making a contribution by virtue of the fact that you are a citizen,
you have a claim to a stock of wealth,
and you also generate assets which create an income. Then, you know,
that's a very different one from sort of hire and fire or resent,
realize neoliberal,
capitalism that people seem to have gotten to the end of the capital.
Same question to you, Eric. Um,
in addition to [inaudible].
What is yours?
Oh, I got plenty more.
The other thing, you know, I, I w I studied economics,
not because it's fascinating, right? I mean, it is costing me,
but I realized that I mainly, but it, it started with moral outrage, which is,
you know, recessions are extraordinarily damaging phenomenon, right?
If we look at so many social traumas are caused by with session, um,
it causes huge, huge human suffering.
And I find that absolutely on forgivable that the economics profession hasn't
got an agreed kind of. So, you know, COVID hits, you can't predict a pandemic,
but we're not surprised that there's a recession. We get, we,
we typically get one at least once a decade on average. Um,
so why weren't we prepared? Right? And I find this infuriating,
and I find that also infuriating that the system we've become reliant on,
which is central banks,
cutting interest rates is an accident of institutional history.
The only reason we have central banks cutting interest rates in response to
recession is because central banks were set up in the 17 and 18 hundreds to
provide liquidity to the banking system and the finance government.
That's why they do asset purchases and good interest rates.
It is clearly not the optimal way to run monetary policy.
And one of the proposals we make in the book, which is,
is becoming acceptable as an idea,
is let's give central banks the power to transfer directly to your bank account.
So when there's a recession, it's really simple, you support everybody's income.
And then when the recession goes away,
you stop supporting their income and wages pick up on the rest of the economy.
The private sector takes over. It's really simple. And it,
all of the evidence we have is that it works because it's,
it's actually not empirically any different to doing a combination of
quantitative easing and tax and tax rebates.
And if you look at the empirical evidence on it, that is a much,
much better supporter of our consumption and spending in our economy,
then all of this quantitative easing and all of these other, you know,
pyrotechnics that, that central banks from engaging.
So I think we need to start messing around and set up a system where the bank of
England, the fed the bank of Japan,
European central bank can have a meeting tomorrow.
And the day after every adult, citizen has a thousand euros, you know,
or thousand dollars pounds in their bank account.
And you do that whilst unemployment persists, and you do more,
if you need to get the economy going,
and then you stop it when the economy is booming, it's as simple as that.
Um, we could go on, but we are out of time. Um,
but I'm going to squeeze in one final question to Mark,
because I really contrast this. So, um, Eric,
you gave a lovely acknowledgement to your family and friends,
Mark, uh, Mark acknowledge, Mark.
You acknowledge your wife's steadfast refusal to engage with anything that you
write. And perhaps this book may prove to be the exception. Was it?
Yes. It wants you read the book. He's not alone either.
I ignored.
Everything he says until this book came out.
Pretty much just ignored. So
reflecting on life more than anything else.
I mean, it's one of those things I said to him. I was like,
how can I acknowledge in the book when you never read that as well? You know,
I listened to you all day, do I have to acknowledge nonsense? He talk all day.
It's a fair enough point. So that was the acknowledgement. But no,
she actually did.
I have to say that's probably the best endorsement for a book I have heard in a
very long time. Thank you very much to,
to Mark and to Eric for your thought provoking book and green now mix.
Now I urge everyone to pick up a copy because the title is angry and I'll
mix,
but after you read it and you will feel less angry because are creative ideas
for moving forward. So thank you to, uh, for the stimulating book, um,
enjoyed the discussion. Um,
and thank you all for watching this podcast reminder for more
podcasts events and all sorts of things.
Please go to intelligence squared.com.
I'm Linda you thank you very much.